[Music]
they say my mother was one of the
greatest to ever rise
stay wild and even though she's been
gone since i was a baby
no
[Music]
there are still moments where i can feel
her spirit
[Music]
welcome to miradero and cora did you
ever see my mom perform
oh yes she was a legend
you look just like your mother
you must be lucky prescott i like your
dress oh and your shoes i didn't know
shoes could be cute
horses can do that is that barn okay
this horse got a lot of spirit you do
have a lot of spirits
easy boy
let's go girl good thing her name's
lucky well is her middle name irony
just rode a horse around here we call
that hanging on for dear life
you are lucky you didn't get yourself
killed you stay away from that horse
that is not his fault i'm trying to keep
you safe he said
let's get out of this town just take it
slow
horses can feel what you feel it's in
your heart to run free
it's in mine too i'm going to call you
spirit
let's round up that hurt boys we need to
get spirit back to his family this is a
terrible
idea
i believe in you lucky you have your
mother's spirit
[Music]
stay wild
trust me
[Music]
go get your family back spirit we'll
need the strength of a thousand
[Music]
marshmallows
[Music]